[Applause]
[Music]
in this video we are going to take a
look at the career of one of the most
surprising and controversial figures of
the century their figure is mikhail
saakashvili
[Music]
wait a second you don't know him well
imagine a person who is capable of being
one of the best allies of Washington and
at the same time one of the greatest
enemies of Vladimir Putin he was
president of one country a candidate to
preside over another and today beat
doesn't even have a nationality this is
a man a politician worthy of starring in
his very own political thriller in fact
I would initially probably wouldn't be
surprising to see a Netflix original
produced about this guy
[Music]
well this is today's character for
visual politic it is mikhail saakashvili
Misha the governor
in order to start our story we need to
go back to May the 30th 2015
oh that's a Petro poroshenko the
presidents of Ukraine appointed mikhail
saakashvili as the governor of the
province of Edessa with this position
Misha was given Ukrainian nationality
however to become a Ukrainian citizen he
had to give up citizenship from his home
country Georgia a country he had led as
president between 2004 and 2013
his addition to the Ukrainian government
was quite the treat for the media and
well that's only logical you see at that
time Ukraine was going through a really
tense situation after the so called mind
and revolution in the fall of
pro-russian President Viktor Yanukovych
there was almost a feeling of civil war
in Ukraine a war between Kiev supporters
and supporters of Moscow and a desert
was one of the most pro-russian
provinces so you can imagine the picture
the phoronix president and not just any
ex-president brought of Putin's worst
enemies appointed as the governor of
Odessa this event was hugely discussed
in all the national media as well as the
international press the president of
Ukraine who was by the way in old friend
and fellow college students of Misha's
Petro poroshenko described tamesha as
the man who makes possible the
impossible pretty flattering right at
that time their friendship when it
seemed bulletproof well the mission of
the new governor was to stabilize adesso
Gran's power to Kiev chase corruption
and set the groundwork for the region to
prosper
[Music]
in order to carry it all out make sure
brought many of his former collaborators
from Georgia he also hired many
Ukrainian young professionals who he
thought to be corruption-free
like Julia Mary chefs Kerr and activist
who became famous here on YouTube with
the video I am a Ukrainian Misha also
brought him some people from Putin's
opposition in Russia like the Russian
activist Maria guider who was appointed
vice governor notice there was a lot to
do and it had to be done fast so well as
it was said so I was done
[Music]
once he took the Odessa governorship the
new governor started a thorough
investigation to find and punish corrupt
public workers he changed most of the
high-level positions in the public
administration he simplified the process
for creating companies and introduced
independent controls and even liberated
public beaches that had been illegally
occupied so that once again
Odessa citizens joy them and hold on a
second here because Nisha has a strange
work methodology and it is as effective
as it is controversial if anything
doesn't work properly and describes he
just dismantle zip he fires all the
workers and he sets it up again he did
the same during his time in office in
Georgia with the traffic police and he
threatened to do it again with the
Edessa port the largest commercial port
in Ukraine well-known for bribes and
payments to customs officers you need to
fire them all we have a hundred and
thirty new people they are young new and
trained and the old ones are hopeless
because in the end they were here Nyanza
pass some of the customs officers so
that the corruption would stop consider
this a number of businessman noted that
bribes at the port really had stopped in
recent months mainly because people were
scared of becoming the next victim of
one of Saakashvili's public
anti-corruption tirades sean walker
correspondent of The Guardian with all
these changes and with the help of
Misha's contacts Edessa started to
receive help from the USA and since
Misha didn't trust the police the first
thing he did was establish an
independent police force to fight
corruption
this was a police force that was
organized and trained by the FBI and the
California Highway Patrol so it looks
like everything was going pretty good
right well just hold on a second because
both Sacagawea and his team soon
realized that it was going to be much
much harder than they anticipated the
problem was that Odessa was not a
battlefield of Kiev supporters versus
pro Russians but it was a battlefield
between the rule of law and an oligarchy
that has dominated Ukraine since its
independence
[Music]
the kingdom of oligarchs
more and more experts of says so
Ukraine's biggest problem is not Russia
it is their oligarchy corruption in
Ukraine is so embedded that we could
almost say it is a sort of feudal
country where the nobility bar of course
these mighty oligarchs they control the
companies the political power the
administration even the media almost
nothing escapes their power which is
consolidated both by money and by fear
their level of impunity is almost
absolute police government judges
they're all a part of the game
things have been this way since Ukraine
got its independence but since the
Maidan revolution it's all got a whole
lot worse after the fall of the
pro-russian President Viktor Yanukovych
and with the civil conflicts the country
was going through the new government
felt incapable of trusting the army or
the police since both institutions were
corrupted were disorganized they were
badly equipped that is why he made a
decision he appointed several oligarchs
as governors of some of the most
vulnerable regions in the country these
oligarchs paid for their own private
armies and with nice incentives the
police followed their orders as well
earning a sum for the head of every
separatist yeah as I told you the
government essentially placed the Mafia
directly in charge of several
governorships well that was the case for
igor kolomoisky who was appointed
governor of denis poplin troske i'm
sorry if i'm screwing the pronunciation
up on that this took like 17 takes this
region is one of the most important in
the country economically speaking so yes
this is the Ukraine mikhail saakashvili
was dealing with there is not a single
state enterprise in Ukraine that has not
been usurped by one clan or another a
varus Abramovich former Minister of
Economy and trade of Ukraine as you can
imagine all these oligarchs did not
welcome me sure or his reform agenda
indeed once he was even kicked out of an
interview when he suggested all of these
mafia members had to be sent to prison
remember that the media is also the
property of the oligarchy the thing is
Misha soon started to work to fight and
ultimately ends the situation
I will do whatever it takes for complete
victory to read Ukraine of this filth of
this corrupt scum which capitalized on
the blood of our soldiers whose only
motivation in life is to fill its own
pockets strengthen its own clan and
bleed Ukraine dry Mikhail Saakashvili
and so he did Mischa started to publicly
report all kinds of influence peddling
favorable treatment and privileges on
one occasion he even came on national
television and reported the details of a
corrupt scheme of the airlines
owned by kolomoiskiy an oligarch who
nearly obtained a monopoly on national
flights the public report ended the
situation and took many of the people
involved to course but as you can
imagine mr. kolomoisky
didn't take it well he promised to get
his revenge and here's what he said
about Saakashvili in public when a dog
without a muzzle bite someone we need to
punish both the dog and more importantly
the owner Igor kolomoisky
now do you know think that only she did
was recalled the oligarchs not at all
[Music]
the train crash saakashvili's reforms in
Edessa didn't completely work many of
them were stopped and sabotaged by the
government in Kiev this wasn't just the
oligarchs you see corruption was so
commonplace that it was difficult to
tell the difference between the Mafia
and the authorities Misha he didn't
think twice the government became his
target many analysts claim that this new
war against the government had a hidden
agenda to take a leap international
politics well maybe but the thing is he
did it he started by reporting the
corruption of the very prime minister
arseniy yatsenyuk men's many ministers
followed this even included his own
friends the president's Petro poroshenko
the person who had placed him in Edessa
what difference for Ukrainians does it
make who will treat them like dirt
poroshenko or you Cunha [ __ ] what
difference who will steal from them
Mikhail Saakashvili the friendship it
didn't last long as we have seen
poroshenko appointed Misha governor in
May of 2015 in just a year the battle
had begun
finally in November 2016 misha resigned
as governor and began his own political
party the mnf and he soon gains more
than 20,000 members yep the former
Georgian presidents now wanted to lead
Ukraine in his own words he aspired to
turn this disaster of a country into a
complete European superpower the Emine
are we wondering about the response of
poroshenko and the government to this
campaign and paid close attention here
in July 2017
poroshenko took advantage of the fact
that Misha was in the USA and he revoked
his Ukrainian citizenship
all of a sudden mikhail saakashvili was
a stateless person
now if you think that stopped him you
are absolutely wrong look when his
nationality was taken away Misha he
simply moved to Poland and we have to
say Misha's a well-loved guy in Eastern
Europe in fact many countries offered
him citizenship but no bishop he was
determined to go back to Ukraine and
well that's exactly what he did
despite the warnings of the government
in Kiev on September the 10th surrounded
by a supportive crowd Misha crossed the
border on foot between Poland and
Ukraine the images of his confrontation
with the border guards well they're
quite a sight
[Music]
[Applause]
and so what do you think he's up to now
that he's back despite his irregular
situation Misha he's campaigning around
the country but all of that said there
is still an important question why
Mikhail Saakashvili
[Music]
the Saakashvili Revolution in 2003 misha
led a popular uprising against the
corrupt georgian political system of
eduard shevardnadze and in what is known
as the Rose Revolution he even made it
to the Georgian Parliament elections
were held man's as these successful
revolutions leader Saakashvili easily
beat the rest the reform process started
there was a fierce fight against
corruption and a tough policy towards
Moscow that came to be a model for the
former Soviet countries but we are going
to discuss these matters as well as the
dark and less camera side of Saakashvili
in a future video right here at visual
politics so do subscribe but for now
it's your turn do you think Misha will
end up leading Ukraine well please do
leave your answers in the comments below
as well as in this survey and do not
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday and
please do check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine and well if you're looking for
something else to watch right now please
do check out my brand new channel bio
graphics we do biographies in the longer
form there are 20 minutes each of
notable people from history and the
present-day politicians and others so go
check it out we'll link in the
description below and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]